how on earth did we manage before the
plastic bag
probably we survived just fine but it's
too late to remember how
in 2010 in europe we used 100 billion
plastic bags
200 for each of europe's 500 million
citizens
could we live without them now a bit of
a shock but just possible according to
shoppers and traders in brussels
somehow i don't really know how good am
i supposed
to come here
but there's a price to pay for that in
brussels they're attempting to keep up
with eu legislators
who've just agreed to force eighty
percent eu-wide bag reductions by 2019
in a pilot that starts next year bags
will be banned in two city districts
foreign
man's relationship with the plastic bag
is schizophrenic at best
one day it's a micro thin maxi strong
aid for everyday life
next day it's an indestructible pest
which like all airborne pests
is tricky to round up they're not only
littering nature and looking terrible
they are also really dangerous in nature
they are
poisoning animals surprising fish
outside in the the sea and it will take
decades we have centuries
to get rid of it an overwhelming
majority of meps agree
passing at parliament's last plenary
session before the elections
legislation to force down public
consumption of bags
by a combination of taxes levies
marketing restrictions and bans
for instance in ireland ireland have
reduced their plastic bags
with 95 within five months
so it's so easy done a lesson there in
good straightforward housekeeping
for us all